Okay.
I hate that we have to do this, but the amount
of disinformation and lies about the virus
coming from our own president is spreading
virally.
So it's not just the virus that's spreading
The lies are spreading virally as well.
We're going to go on a tour now.
None of the lies that Donald Trump has told
during his presidency that numbers about 16000.
It would take us months to go through them.
We are going to go on a tour of lies, not
from the entire coronavirus crisis, because
that would take weeks.
We're just doing a partial tour of the lies
that Donald Trump has told and spread just
during the last few days about Corona virus.
Look at the havoc that this man is wreaking.
First, Donald Trump insisted that he did everything
right away and correctly when it comes to
the Defense Production Act.
This is a mechanism that harkens back to 1950
and the Korean War.
I misstated yesterday that this was a World
War Two era thing.
It's a Korean War era thing from 1950.
The idea is that in a time of a national emergency
war pandemic, whatever, the government can
essentially force industry to produce things
that are needed for the war or the pandemic.
Trump invoked the act supposedly, but didn't
enforce it or use it, saying it's a tool that's
ready if I need it.
But I don't actually need it now.
We need ventilators.
We need masks urgently.
This has been a completely incoherent explanation
from Donald Trump and the New York Times appears
to have figured out the conundrum.
Trump has been lobbied successfully by the
United States Chamber of Commerce not to actually
use the Defense Production Act because they
don't like it.
So Trump has been twisting himself into a
pretzel the last two or three briefings to
say this incoherent thing of, well, I invoke
it, but I haven't used it.
It's ready and I'm doing everything right.
And it's a lie.
And it appears to be because industry successfully
lobbied him not to use it.
Number two, Trump continues to hype chloroquine
and a zero myson as a possible game changer,
something he thinks will be the cure for a
corona virus.
We've already gone over this in detail.
It's not a game changer.
It's a possible thing.
Side effects are a big issue.
Reports of heart and vision issues are starting
to come in.
And once again, the surgeon general had to
go on Fox News, where Trump's this information
spreads quickly and say, no, this.
And we're going to look at this.
This is right after Fox and Friends had Dr.
Oz on spreading more of it.
Here is Surgeon General Jerome Adams explaining
that this is not a cure.
This is not what Trump is claiming this this
to be.
You know, Doctor, we had Dr. Oz on at the
top of this hour.
And what he talked about was how promising
he thinks that malaria drug, when used in
concert with Ze Pack, was with one of the
French doctors who treated 36 people.
And their viral level all went from 100 down
to zero after just five or six days.
He said his biggest problem right now and
he's starting his own clinical trials at Columbia
and he mentioned the Cleveland Clinic.
I think it's going to do the same thing.
He wonders and worries about the fact that
we don't have enough pills yet in this country.
If that works.
Well, here's the thing about those drugs.
There's May and there's and there's actually
does.
And so these may be promising.
And so we're trying to make them as available
as possible to people across the country.
We need to verify through studies that they
actually work.
But I also, again, want to go back to the
fact that we are why it's not practical to
think we're going to treat our way out of
this problem with new drugs or with ventilators
or with supplies.
We need to lower demand.
We need more people talking about staying
at home.
That's why I reached out to Kylie Jenner last
week.
It's why my kids say, dad, reach out to Lauren
Gray and Roman Atwood and have them help these
millennials understand their spreading virus.
And the more they spread, the more we're going
to need these drugs, the more we're going
to need ventilators and masks.
So there's an actual doctor trying to push
back against Trump's hyperbole and distortion
because he is being deceptive, he is spreading
disinformation, and it already led to one
death.
I'll tell you about that later.
Continuing our true or our tour of Donald
Trump's Corona virus lies of just the last.
Two days, Trump is starting to tweet.
He did it Sunday night.
He did it.
Monday night.
This morning, he's starting to tweet that
maybe we're going to wrap up the social distancing,
the physical distancing.
This is very dangerous.
And meanwhile, state governors who are dealing
with this in a more real way are putting in
place shelter in place orders.
We just got one yesterday here in Massachusetts
and other states are getting them as well.
But meanwhile, Donald Trump is spreading flat
out dangerous speculation by tweeting Sunday
night that, quote, We cannot let the cure
be worse than the problem itself.
At the end of the 15 day period, we will make
a decision as to which way we want to go.
Trump began tweeting this morning, We are
going to get people back to work, but we're
going to take care of older folks.
Trump's economic adviser, Larry Kudlow, also
starting to parrot this, saying we don't want
the cure to be worse than the disease.
And this is extremely dangerous.
Number one, there is no way in hell that all
we need is another seven days.
Number two, you have people who are desperate
to start going out and do whatever they want,
which I can understand.
I mean, I want to do it also.
But we can't give people any cover under which
to do it.
And Trump is lying here and he shouldn't be
saying this.
And then lastly, one of the reasons Trump
claims that he doesn't need to enforce the
Defense Production Act is that GM and Ford
are already making ventilators and everything's
great.
This is just a lie.
No automaker is anywhere near ready to make
ventilators.
GM General Motors reportedly says they have
a plan for starting to obtain most, but not
all of the parts they would need to be able
to begin.
The manufacturer of ventilators at some point
in the future, it will realistically take
months for them to even actually start churning
out ventilators.
They also don't need Trump's permission to
do it, which Trump hasn't been saying, with
my permission, GM is doing this.
It is lie after lie after lie.
And it's going to get much, much worse.
One of the things about Donald Trump is that
the more difficult things get, the more likely
he is to lie uncontrollably.
And this is getting more and more difficult.
The death toll is climbing here in the U.S.
You should expect the lies to continue.
My hope is that our state governors can help
fight this because Trump's causing problems.
The state governors that are taking this seriously.
Cuomo, Newsome, Baker, others.
I know I'm missing a lot of people.
He doesn't understand anything about medicine
or the virus.
And the governors are having to basically
work against Trump in favor of sanity and
reason.
People around Trump keep explaining this stuff.
Yesterday during the press conference from
started asking Dr. Burke's questions that
made it clear he barely knows anything about
asymptomatic contagion or any of this stuff.
He doesn't get pandemics.
He doesn't understand virality.
And there are.
This is a very bad time for this degree of
weaponized ignorance, incompetence and delusions
of grandeur.
And we may very quickly get into this battle
between Trump saying get back to work and
governors and probably airlines and others
saying, no, no, no, we're not.
We're not doing it.
And that may happen sooner than later.